programa começa o cara tá no helicóptero
né O cara tá
aqui pra eu entrar nessa
Ilha eu não tenho como pousar então eu
vou ter que pular nesse Rio cheio de
crocodilos que não comem há uma semana
Tomara que eu tenha sorte hein uh aí ele
pula no Rei e pula cai lá com jacaré
mesmo fosse comigo o cara falasse olha
só tem como entrar nessa Ilha pulando
nessa água e essa água tem 2000 jacaré
eu ia voltar pra televisão ia falar ô
rapaz porque não deu mesmo para gravar
chegamos lá o cara disse que tinha
15.000 jacaré na água aí eu achei
impertinente né da minha parte eu pular
dentro dessa água aí ele fica perdido na
ilha Ah estou perdido você não tá
perdido o cara foi lá e te deixou aí ele
sabe muito bem Onde você tá Se você
quiser ir embora só você levantar a mão
assim ó vou morrer o cara vai e pega
você ai estou perdido estou com medo eu
estou me desidratando o que é
isso essa rã